Hi! Today we're in Tokyo, the capital of Japan.
So, this is Tokyo at night.
It's beautiful.
Yeah, it's a big city.
It has about 12 million people.
Wow, it looks like a fun city to visit.
Oh yeah! Tokyo is really fun at night.
You can hear music, dance, eat great food.
Tokyo is famous for its bright lights and busy streets.
Wow, look at all those TV screens!
How many are there?
Oh, I don't know.
There are a lot.
Electronics are really big in Tokyo and they even have elephants on the street.
Huh?
Yeah, look at the TV screen.
Cool, I see them.
Okay, now we're in one of Tokyo's train stations.
A lot of Tokyo's stations are underground.
And you can take the trains anywhere in the city?
To a lot of places, yeah.
You can travel by train around Tokyo...
...from five o'clock in the morning to one o'clock at night.
And Japan has a lot of different kinds of trains, right?
Yup, some can go at 300 kilometers per hour.
Wow, that is fast.
It's a great place for shopping, too.
It looks good for clothes shopping.
Yeah, and for electronics.
People here really love cool new things.
Cellphones.
Digital cameras.
Cool TVs.
Computers.
And fashion is big here, too.
There are some great clothes stores in Tokyo.
It looks like this city is busy 24 hours a day.
It usually is.
Yeah, Tokyo is a cool city.